you very very much it's um it's an
amazing feeling it feels like I'm in a
dream still experienced yeah and you
know are those emotions though mix they
can see how happy you are I mean
obviously a huge achievement but are
your emotions mixed because of what
happened to your father absolutely i
mean they were mix the whole way through
and it was incredibly difficult at times
but my my overriding feeling is that i
managed to bring my father back to shore
which is something that I it's
completely taken me two boats blow me
away and it's it was one of the most
emotional two months of my life I did a
lot of crying out there and a lot of
talking to him and I'm just delighted I
feel like I finally brought him out of
the Pacific and back to dry land well
you know that is an amazing emotion and
amazing sentiment there so obviously you
know we can't underestimate how
difficult this is your father obviously
kept you going there oh absolutely um he
was he was there the whole way he was
there the whole way um and it was it was
powerful because there's there's really
really tough moments mentally physically
I was fine but mentally I really
struggled at times and just this
overriding sense that he was right there
with me it was incredible and I don't
I've come back and I've learned that
I've learned that he's so much part of
me as well I don't necessarily need to
go back again and I probably worried to
be honest look I'm fascinated how old
were you when Dad went missing I was
four and a half years old when he went
missing 96 yeah and still but unfinished
story between you and him and that
inspiration and that influence that he's
had on you let's try and understand him
he did this journey once he did this
cross him once why did he need to do it
twice he rode from san francisco to
australia in 83 and became the first man
to its if 'ok and then in 1996 and all
through my life during the 90s he was
rolling from russia towards San
Francisco to be the first man to do it
you know he know he couldn't really tell
you why he wanted to do it it's because
it was there and you know I see him as a
hero this is only it's only made me
you know love the man more Mr Man more
and i'm just i'm on you know i'm honored
to be a son and it's been an incredible
journey um yeah yeah well as you say you
brought him home he'll be looking down
on you and i just want to share my
experience with you I was like on a
motor boat on sunday i was doing some
filming and this was off the the coast
of monte carlo so the mediterranean was
you know relatively calm compared to you
everybody's just gone all in my ear yeah
that's how I spent my weekend but it was
work it was work my goodness me did it
make me queasy oh ha I mean it was for
the rest the day was ruined I mean you
just white green whatever how do you
deal with seasickness I took some of the
Isaacs and Jeremy Hill was very very
start and I treat you I thought I was
gonna be in a bad bad way I was nervous
about it but I managed to get my sea
legs pretty quick it must be in the
genes and from there on you just get
into the motion of it and it just
becomes your new life you know you're
rowing 12 hours a day two hours on two
hours of it's tough I mean it is tough
and I struggled I really struggled with
I struggled with being so remote and you
know separated from my family and my
people i love i really struggled being
that cut off from the real world and you
know thankfully I felt like my old man
was right there with me and we came in
together which is you know it's
incredibly powerful well welcome back to
the real world before you go show me the
palms of your hands blisters oh yeah so
V European Louie feel your pain but
congratulations well done to you and
your dad thanks for sharing it with us
congratulations thank you very much
indeed take care guys